[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio y las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos de este caso con movimiento
en contra del racismo el odio y el
maltrato hacia la comunidad asiática en
eeuu ha venido creciendo en los últimos
días y se ha expandido a través de
internet durante el último año la
retórica y los ataques hacia esta
población ha incrementado en parte
debido al origen del cob y 19 cuál es el
contexto de esta situación
empezamos la historia de hoy se centra
en eeuu este martes 16 de enero un
hombre ingresó a tres salones de masajes
en la ciudad de atlanta y asesinó a
tiros a ocho personas seis de ellas eran
mujeres de origen asiático las
autoridades aún investigan el motivo del
crimen y aunque el sospechoso que
posteriormente fue capturado negó que
estuviera motivado por un odio racial
los hechos coinciden con una creciente
ola de ataques y discriminación hacia
los estadounidenses de ascendencia
asiática sólo hace unas semanas el país
se conmocionó ante varios reportes de
agresión hacia personas mayores
la comunidad y que fueron capturados en
vídeo estos episodios recibieron un
contundente rechazo que se vio en las
calles pero especialmente en internet
hashtag tap visión hate que podría
traducirse como paren el odio hacia los
asiáticos es un movimiento que ya se
venía gestando en redes sociales hace
unos meses pero tomó fuerza a raíz de
los recientes ataques en twitter
facebook e instagram por ejemplo miles
de usuarios entre los que se encuentran
personajes de la política y el
entretenimiento usaron este numeral para
mostrar su solidaridad hacia esta
comunidad en eeuu en tick tock por
ejemplo miles de usuarios refirieron a
la problemática denunciaron los ataques
compartieron sus experiencias personales
y hasta recordaron y condenaron la
xenofobia y los estereotipos que se
promueven en el mundo del
entretenimiento otros por su parte
celebraron el movimiento pero creen que
no es suficiente y dicen que hacen falta
acciones para lograr cambios y salvar
vidas
este es mi problema con él
hate básicamente y no va lo
suficientemente lejos reduce todo a la
discriminación todo el racismo anti
asiático a unas pocas instancias de
crímenes de odio durante el último par
de meses en la realidad el racismo de
más acerca de narrativas como cuando mi
ex jefe que era un hombre vietnamita
dijo que no me metiera en la política
porque eeuu como que elegiría una
persona asiática
eso es una narrativa o la visión
personal katzenberg no podemos apoyar
ciegamente cualquier activismo contra el
racismo hacia los asiáticos solo porque
estamos enojados sin objetivos tangibles
no veremos un cambio real porque el
activismo reaccionario solo resultará en
un enojo corto y desgaste estoy de
acuerdo en que necesitamos unidad y
presionar por un cambio pero pienso que
podemos hacerlo en una forma que sea
productiva un reciente informe del
centro para el estudio del odio y el
extremismo de la universidad estatal de
california mostró que los delitos de
odio contra los asiáticos
estadounidenses en 16 ciudades
importantes de eeuu aumentaron en un 149
por ciento entre 2019 y 2020 un período
en el que los delitos de odio en general
cayeron en un 7% otro reciente reporte
de ésta
y hay una organización que rastrea
incidentes de discriminación odio y
xenofobia contra estadounidenses de
origen asiático e isleños del pacífico
mostró que entre marzo de 2020 y febrero
del presente año se reportaron tres mil
795 incidentes contra asiáticos solo en
eeuu pero las cifras se refiere sólo a
los hechos reportados encontró también
que el acoso verbal o los apodos son el
principal tipo de discriminación y que
después del trabajo y la calle internet
es el tercer lugar donde más se observan
estos problemas de los que los
ciudadanos chinos son las principales
víctimas las fechas coinciden con los
días en que el kobe 19 se esparció por
todo el mundo son nuevos este tipo de
ataques
ahora son más visibles se lo preguntamos
a ryan john wayne un joven
estadounidense de origen vietnamita y
activista del movimiento station hate
y creo que este tipo de ataques siempre
han sucedido desde el inicio de la
historia de eeuu es sólo que ahora son
más numerosos y los medios han empezado
a cubrir los más porque la gente ha
empezado a expresarse pero en términos
de si es un nuevo fenómeno no lo creo
creo que el racismo anti asiático y la
violencia siempre han estado ahí solo
que ahora está sucediendo en números más
altos existen en el bar gran versión en
enero del presidente joe biden firmó una
orden ejecutiva que denuncia la
discriminación contra los asiáticos tras
el reciente tiroteo la casa blanca dijo
que la retórica del ex presidente de
donald trump tuvo mucho que ver con las
situaciones que estamos viendo contra
los asiáticos estadounidenses
esto condujo a percepciones de la
comunidad asiático estadounidense que
son inexactas injustas ha planteado
amenazas ha aumentado las amenazas
contra los asiáticos estadounidense the
tracks against es un emergente según el
censo de eeuu los estadounidenses de
origen asiático eran más de 21 millones
en 2019 lo que representa el 6.6 por
ciento de toda la
california tiene el número de asiáticos
estadounidenses más grande de todo el
territorio más de 6.500.000 seguido por
nueva york con casi 2 millones son
justamente estos dos estados desde donde
se reportan el mayor número de
incidentes según stop
hate en mayo de 2020 un estudio del
centro de investigación pew encontró que
los estadounidenses de origen asiático
son el segmento de votantes elegibles de
más rápido crecimiento entre los
principales grupos raciales y étnicos
del país los medios de comunicación de
eeuu registran cómo se vive en estos
casos dentro de las comunidades
asiáticas en el país
el washington post titula los ataques
ante asiáticos aumentaron junto con el
vitriolo en línea una palabra utilizada
para referirse a la retórica mordaz
añade que los datos muestran que
términos como china wuhan y gripe han
surgido en los foros de extrema derecha
en telegram el kun y de donald punto win
desde las elecciones en bici nos dice
que las comunidades asiático
estadounidenses están nerviosas a medida
que aumentan los ataques mientras que
cnn titula que los estadounidenses de
origen asiático ya vivían con miedo y
que los asesinatos del spam
el área de atlanta se sienten como una
escalada aterradora para ellos hasta
aquí revista digital recuerde que si
quiere repetir esta u otra misión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto
francisco 4 puntos
[Música]